this is an awesome prep by Anish gir
look at the clock he's got more time
than what he started with he continues
to put the pressure continues to Blitz
out the moves and this is so
uncomfortable for maxim who actually is
one of the biggest grinfield Experts of
all time rookie three you pointed out is
the big threat on the board The Black
Queen would have no Escape Route C8
which apparently is arguably a losing
mistake because now white suddenly can
take on E7 the point being that after
Rook takes E1 Rook takes E1 this bishop
is still not hanging because after Queen
E7 sorry Rook takes C E7 we
have Rook C1 C8 here and this is why we
played H3 all those moves ago right this
is a big moment then Peter if Anish
spots Bishop E7 and the tactics that onu
it could mean game over for Maxi it
seems it seems incredibly bad yeah